now move to politics president donald
trump has been impeached again that
happened yesterday
he's now the first president to be
impeached twice capitol hill proceedings
now moved to the senate for a trial
republican senate majority leader mitch
mcconnell says he will not reconvene his
fellow senators early to begin that
trial
mcconnell is also not saying how he'll
vote on those charges
the president of course was impeached
over the riots at the capitol last week
the associated press reports the trial
though could start on inauguration day
in the video released last night
president trump made no mention of that
second impeachment but instead warned
against more violence
no true supporter of mine could ever
endorse
political violence no true supporter of
mine
could ever disrespect law enforcement
or our great american flag
so far today new fencing has been put up
around the capitol and other buildings
in washington d.c
up to 20 000 national guard troops are
expected to be in washington ahead
of president-elect biden's inauguration